Dad.
Yeah?
You have company.
Hey, buddy, how's it going?
Hey, Norb, how you doing?
I'm Mike and this is Frank.
- I'm Frank.
Nice to meet ya.
And your daughter Heather--
OK.
--called our shop in
Iowa and told us that
you might have some
motorcycle parts
you're interested in selling.
[music playing]
I'm not really interested
and don't know why
my daughter called you guys.
Yeah, well, I get that.
I mean--
I'm just saying.
--I've got stuff I
wouldn't sell either.
I understand.
OK, I got bikes but
they're all old friends.
- Sure.
- I know exactly what you mean.
- Yeah.
- I bought a--
I bought a motorcycle
when I was 15.
I still got it.
- Do ya?
Yep.
MIKE: Oh, yeah, we
both ride quite a bit.
One of the bike's in
there is kinda--it's been
with us over 40 years.
Over 40 years?
MIKE: Really?
I'll be darned.
MIKE: Which one's that?
That's my knucklehead.
- Oh, the knucklehead.
- Yeah.
Oh.
That's his baby.
That's his baby?
- That's his baby, Frank.
- That's his baby.
Awesome.
Well, why don't you take him
inside and show them around.
Would you guys
like to come in?
FRANK: We would love to come in.
MIKE: Yeah, look
around, Heck, yeah.
FRANK: Oh, yeah, this
looks good, Norb.
JD, VL.
This looks like Norbert's shop
where he works on his bikes
and spends some alone time.
Here's your baby.
NORBERT: Oh yeah.
FRANK: And sitting
by the entrance
is his 1946 knucklehead.
It's got an orange and
black paint job on it.
I mean, it's got the
beehive taillight.
NORBERT: Oh yeah.
FRANK: It's got a luggage rack.
It's got a cigarette lighter
with a coil cover over it.
It's even got a European
speedometer on it.
This thing is trick.
MIKE: In the 1970s,
people were building
bikes that were expressing
what was happening
in the counterculture.
Guys were cutting and
chopping everything back then.
But this bike he spared.
He wanted to leave
it bone stock.
This was a bike
that he was really
going to honor its history.
And the fact that he
hasn't erased all of that
is incredible.
FRANK: Can we hear it run?
- Sure.
[motorcycle engine starts]
Hey.
Really good job.
- That's pretty cool, man.
- Pretty good.
MIKE: When you hear that engine,
that big twin, it comes alive.
Yeah.
MIKE: If you've ridden
a bike like this,
you can appreciate
that sound even more.
That baby fired right up.
NORBERT: Well,
she's a good old--
she gets temperamental
sometimes.
Oh, yeah.
I don't want to walk
off this property
without this knucklehead.
It's a $30,000 bike, and
I'm ready to just step
up if he'll consider an offer.
Have you ever thought about
selling this over the years?
NORBERT: I've had some thoughts
and entertained some offers.
But it's an old friend.
FRANK: I got ya.
MIKE: I hear ya.
NORBERT: I had it
for over 40 years.
I can still start it.
I can still ride it.
MIKE: Yeah.
- Do you still ride it?
- Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Well, think it
over a little bit.
Well, weddings and funerals.
I don't really know you,
and you want my knucklehead?
What are your qualifications?
You know?
I better get off this here.
I'm getting too used to it.
You know, I'm really
in love with this bike.
But right now Norbert is
saying he's not selling.
And I'm not surprised.
- I'm going to look--
I'm going to look
around a little bit.
- By all means.
- Alrighty.
Please.
But his wife and his
daughter said he needs to sell.
So I'm going to put the bike on
the back burner for right now.
But I'm not done yet.
You think we could take another
look at the knucklehead?
You can look all you want.
All right.
Look but don't touch?
- No, you can touch it.
- All right.
- I let you touch it earlier.
- All right, that's a fact.
- You know?
- I know, I sat on it.
- You just got to be gentle.
- It's all good. you know?
- It felt good.
- Yeah.
Be gentle, Frank.
I'm practicing my windup.
We've bought a few things here.
Norbert's happy with our prices.
I'm get ready to slow
pitch on that knucklehead.
So we've been walking around.
We did the circle.
- Mm-hm.
Mike's bought some
parts and stuff from ya.
What about the knuckle here?
What do you think?
NORBERT: I know every bearing
in this thing, every part.
A lot of them I've made.
This is my pride and joy.
And I've owned it for
well over 40 years.
Ah-- I'd really like
to help you out.
But the knucklehead's family.
FRANK: It's family?
NORBERT: The knucklehead is
part of me, part of the family.
I can still ride it.
It's staying here.
I can understand.
I can understand why he kept it.
I can understand why
it's not for sale.
Right.
NORBERT: Like I said,
hey, when I can't start it
and I can't ride it,
I'll give you a call.
All right.
Frank, I'm going to
grab some of these parts.
FRANK: All right.
Today wasn't my time.
But that's not the only
knucklehead around.
MIKE: Careful on the heads.
FRANK: Yeah, put these
in a box in there.
If I could pick any
one that I really want,
it would be the first
year 1936 knucklehead.
Life's all about timing.
There'll be one down the line.
MIKE: All right.
Appreciate you.
You guys have
a good safe trip.
I had a good time.
Thanks a lot for
the parts and stuff.
Appreciate the parts.
I want to thank you
for the entertainment.